[Applause]
[Music]
it's the hottest ticket in town
because it's the first ticket in town
tribeca will be the first
in-person film festival to take place in
all of north america
since the pandemic began over a year ago
it's also a key milestone
the 20th anniversary of the festival the
festival was founded shortly after the 9
11 attacks on the world trade center
to help revitalize the devastated nearby
tribeca neighborhood
as well as the rest of new york city
film critic allison wilmore says that
after covet 19 hit new york city
particularly hard last year
tribeca's original message of hope rings
truer than ever
now the festival is on its 20th
anniversary and it's
kind of in the wake of a trauma again
and in this case
you really feel that the festival is
trying to coax people back outside you
know back
out to the movies out to outdoor
screenings
and out to this kind of general activity
in a city that's slowly reopening
[Music]
the festival kicks off fittingly perhaps
within the heights
a new york set story adapted from
lin-manuel miranda's award-winning
broadway musical
other highlights include the world
premiere of steven soderbergh's
no sudden move
and roadrunner a behind the scenes film
about the life of the late new york chef
author and tv host anthony bourdain but
it's also a festival where
new filmmakers are hoping to make their
mark
like with this tv docu-series
incarceration nations
about prison systems around the world
director and writer
baz dreisinger says tribeca is a welcome
opportunity
it's amazing to be a part of any
in-person event frankly
as a as a filmmaker as an artist as an
activist
to be able to interact with audiences
again to do this in person and
it also feels like you know not only the
eyes of all of new york but the
the world and is watching june 19th will
be another highlight
because that's when the radio city music
hall will reopen for the first time
after being closed for more than a year
because of the coronavirus pandemic
it will host the closing night film of
tribeca
all of the audience will be fully
vaccinated and
masks will be optional it will be a
landmark event
not only for the festival but for this
city as a whole
gabriel zondo al jazeera new york